[Music]
hey it's Jordan and we are going to look
through my bag I travel a lot so that's
why I have this big bag and I got sent
this bag by one person has my initials
first things first I have this Capri
coconut rose
toner just to refresh my face this is
amazing for flights just during the day
it smells beautiful cuz it's coconut a
charger always even though I feel like I
should probably have one of those
portable case ones but I feel like that
I recharge your phone that good got
headphones air phone sorry which is kind
of annoying stock of iPhone 7 and you
have to have the iPhone earphones which
is kind of annoying because I do prefer
having like my beats unless you have
that connecting thing which I don't so I
use these my favorite scent is the
Scylla Ron black opium I always get
compliments from this uber drivers
always saying oh you smell nice madam
and I tell them so this is like my go-to
evening day and night and notebook
believe in yourself
my goals what I want to do raise your
standards be great everything you do
wake up to a brand new day being around
Tyra Banks spending time with cigar
making new friendships what book
look I'm currently reading is over joy
you can stand by debris nah Jackson
Gandhi is like a really good book with
101 principles to live by so you can
just go through any chapter I think I'm
on this one now 33 your body is a
communication tool my hoodie dress from
my new collection with London a
misguided because it gets really cold
sometimes on the plane or just if I just
want to like update my look real quick I
can just wear this I have this therapy
or a spray I'm all about aura and energy
and just you know something less than
that uplift me so I just spritz this on
breathe in breathe out and I like hunter
scent feel better
my Eastern purse and my baby bubble got
for me for Christmas
credit cards cash
Virgin Atlantic membership staff I have
my vivid hot lip gloss which is my
favorite it's a nice nude however you
like color on my lips I just go for new
so this let my go-to and then I have my
less sensational
which I Kris use a couple these are like
my go-to maybe products my iPhone my
go-to app I guess what I always go to
Instagram see what everybody else is
doing in their life and at my favorite
account to follow at the moment is cardi
B because she's just so real and funny
and obsessed with her I have a Buddha
just because just again for good luck in
common and just and the key I don't know
what that school yeah at the end of
everyone's bag it's just rubbish really
like look at that oh and a $5 so that's
it guys
thank you for watching for more videos
like this subscribe for glamour